euh peut-être aussi dans vos journaux
les dépenses de l'Élysée ont sacrément
augmenté euh cette année ils ont même
exposé selon un rapport de
l'observatoire de l'éthique publique il
pourrait atteindre jusqu'à 127 millions
d'euros d'ici la fin de l'année euh
regardez peut-être voilà le budget qui a
été voté les prévisions de budget donc
les dépenses vous allez nous expliquer
ça très bien il y a donc une
augmentation de 12 à 15 % quand même par
rapport à l'année précédente on a voulu
savoir euh combien coûtaient les
costumes d'
les déplacs d'Emmanuel Macron et
Brigitte Macron budget donc qui qui
explose d'abord un peut-être Émilie
comment comment ça se fait ça 12 à 15 %
de plus pourquoi cette année plus que
l'année dernière qu'estce il y a eu plus
de déplacement plus de costume plus de
je sais pas de réception alors je pense
que oui l'Élysée explique ça par les
déplacements c'est-à-dire que Emmanuel
Macron a beaucoup plus insisté sur la
diplomatie sur international on peut le
comprendre il a des difficultés à gérer
l'interne puisqu'il y a pas de majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
plus plus difficile d'avoir la main
finalement là-dessus et il essaie
d'avoir une stature un peu
internationale on l'a vu beaucoup bon il
y a des raisons aussi il y a la guerre
en Ukraine qui continue là il y a les
questions autour d'Israël qui qui
commencent donc il y a beaucoup de
choses qui qui ont prêté justement à des
déplacements mais a priori il y a eu un
un forcing sur les déplacements moi je
dirais qu'il y a eu aussi ces 100 jours
d'apaisement et d'action où on avait un
espèce d'Emmanuel Macron qui était un
petit peu omniprésent qui faisait tous
les ministres à la fois il jouaient tous
les rôles il se déplaçaient beaucoup il
y a eu beaucoup d'avions à priori à la
place du train pour des raison de
rapidité pour être un peu là partout et
probablement ça a augmenté augmenté ce
qui est pas choquant le budget en
lui-même on sait que l'Élysée a besoin
de l'argent on sait qu'il y a des frais
de représentation on sait qu'il y a
besoin de diplomatie qui a besoin de
dîner officiel comme celui de Versailles
pour Charles I mais c'est peut-être ce
dérapage qui est un petit peu plus
choquant parce qu'on est en augmentation
il y avait déjà eu une augmentation en
2022 et puis surtout c'est le contexte
qui est qui est difficile c'est-à-dire
qu' on comprend pas comment ce président
qui se présente comme la start-up nation
avec beaucoup de tabl xel très branché
sur l'économie sur les tableurs xel
comment il n'a pas veillé à pas déraper
parce que symboliquement c'est très
mauvais de donner cette image c'est vrai
que quand on pense à des pauvres
familles qui comptent à l'euro prêt pour
leur budget mensuel c'est difficile de
se dire l'Élysée des rabes de 12 à 15 %
si on fait pour on va détailler peutre C
dépens parce que je suis sûr que ceux
qui nous regardent ceux qui sont ici
autour de nous ont beaucoup de questions
à poser sur les dépenses qu'est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron a le droit et
Brigitte Macron de dépenser ou pas mais
d'abord jeis savoir peut-être bon Damien
est-ce que ces chiffres ce chiffre vous
choque est-ce que cette hausse vous
choque moi ça me choque pas parce que le
budget de l'Élysée est à l'image du
budget de tous les ménages avec
effectivement quelques millions en plus
si je dire mais le coût de l'énergie qui
augmente ça je suis pas sûr qu'Emmanuel
Macron règle la facture d'électricité de
l'É je sais
pas vous parliez des déplacements c'est
vrai que les déplacements ont été plus
importants mais il y a aussi la hausse
des des coûts des transports aussi qui
qui doit aussi se prendre en pleine
figure Emmanuel Macron donc c'est vrai
qu'il y a a peut-être un petit dérapage
dont vous avez parlé mais il y a aussi
une part qui ne lui est pas forcément
imputable à Emmanuel Macron je pense que
le problème c'est que le problème c'est
le contexte actuel c'est-à-dire qu'on a
du mal à comprendre berc qui commence à
nous dire il faut serrer la ceinture il
y a plus le quoi quiil en coûte c'est la
fin de l'abondance et c'est symbolique
c'est-à-dire que se dire que l'Élysée ne
veille pas à ça il le sait qu'il y a le
prix de l'énergie qui augmente il le
sait que l'avion c'est plus cher donc
c'est juste avoir la la la maîtrise de
ça on a un peu le sentiment que c'est le
fait ce que je dis mais pas ce que je
fais un petit peu S quand il nous dit
enu la colle roulé faites un effort de
sobriété euh voilà prês de son petit
chauffage effectivement baisser le
chauffageiss
chage 17 maximum et que après on voit
les dépenses alors effectivement il y a
eu des déplacements diplomatiques et
Cera mais surtout le budget ce que dit
la Cour des comptes c'est que c'est pas
une obligation en fait c'est une
tradition voilà il y a un budget
effectivement qui àoue les services d'un
coiffeur les pour voilà pour pour les
représentations mais en fait c'est pas
un D pour le président de la République
et pour Brigitte Macron outre les
transports est-ce que vous avez listé
les oh bah il y a tous les listings mais
moi j'ai j'ai pas envie de faire le
maquill alors si il y avait eu un point
au tout début du du premier quinquena
d'Emmanuel Macron sur le maquillage la
coiffure des posts des posts qui étaient
assez importants et qu'il a fallu
réduire des fleurs il y a eu beaucoup
aussi de réhabilitation attendez dans le
budget d'élisé il y a aussi l'envelppe
de Brigit Macron oui il y a l'enveloppe
de Brigitte Macron et puis il y a le
patrimoine qu's ont beaucoup rénové la
moquette il y a des choses comme ça qui
rentrent là-dedans après moi je vais pas
m'amuser à venir
hés par contre il y a des présidents
comme Françis Holland qui av décidé il
sétait dit y a un plafond c'est 100
millions et basta je n'irait pas plus
haut Sarkozy était plutôt dépensier
comme Emmanuel Macron regardez les
dépenses qui ont été listé regardez un
cabinet le cabinet fonctionne pour un
cabinet
pour c'était deux fois plus par exemple
pour beaucoup plus crise de 2008 la
crise bancaire de 2008 pour pour Nicolas
sarzi c'est vrai mais la situation était
peutêtre peu différ 5200 € par mois pour
la coiffeuse mais oui mais c fois plus
au début des premers du premier qu on
fait quoi pour vous AZ vu ch il sont
magnifque c'est quoi c'est non mais
attendez on fait quoi pour 5200 € par
mois il est tout le temps s les fe de la
MO j'imagine très très mal Macron en
train de faire les comptes tous les
soirs de la comptabilité de ce qu'il a
dépensé ou pas donc il y a des gens qui
sont là pour pour le faire est-ce que
c'est lui qui négocie les les salaires
des coiffeurs des maquilleurs de l'achat
c'est certainement pas lui donc est-ce
qu'il maîtrise véritablement ce type de
Budet est-ce que c'est lui qui est avec
son épouse vraiment à la source de
toutes ces dépenses ou est-ce que c'est
pas plutôt le cabinet ministériel qui
doit s'occuper de ça non il il y a aussi
une charge très importante dont on parle
pas beaucoup SII dans le budget
d'Emmanuel de Brigitte Macron c'est le
personnel c'est le personnel qui coûte
cher et ce que je trouve assez cocasse
c'est que l'Élisée dit bah oui mais vous
vous rendez compte il y a l'indice de
des fonctionnaires qui a augmenté donc
ça va nous ça nous coûte plus cher il y
a les marchés publics qui sont
renégociés donc ça nous coûte plus cher
mais en fait c'est la vie des
entreprises c'est ça que je trouve un
petit peu choquant al la vie des
entreprises publiques mais mais on a du
mal à comprendre que l'Élysée ne se
fasse pas une exigence de maîtriser ça
c'est plus ça que que ça coûte de
l'argent on peut le comprendre mais qui
a une exigence de dire attendez on va
pas dépenser plus de 10 % on va pas
augmenter le budget plus de 10 % par
exemple moi je suis désolé c'est un
petit peu l'arbre qui cache la forêt
cette histoire parce que le problème en
France c'est qu'on a un appareil d'État
extrêmement lourd qui coûte cher avec le
même nombre d'élus en France qu'aux
États-Unis sauf que les États-Unis c'est
un petit peu plus grand vous voyez le
problème il est là c'est que on pas tout
à fait le même système social la même
protection
sociale ça n'a rien à voir avec les
députés ça n'a rien à voir avec les
députés ou le Parlement enfin ça ça ça
n'a rien à voir la sécurité sociale
c'est autre chose c'est que l'appareil
d'État coûte très cher et les Français
ont du mal à comprendre qu'on puisse
augmenter quelque chose dans le cadre
déjà de quelque chose qui est en record
de dépenses dans le monde oui
l'évaluation l'évaluation ça c'est vrai
vous avez raison c'est-à-dire de où on
dépense où on met le paquet et où est-ce
qu'on fait des économies on a beaucoup
de mal à le faire en France que ça soit
globalement ou à les liser alors on va
prendre un poste de budget les vacances
du couple présidentiel au fort de Bregan
il loue pas parce que ça c'est une
piscine en plus
voilà c'est à dispo donc il loupe pas
mais quand même 400000 € de budget de
sécurité 60000 € de budget pour chaque
baignade en mer plongeur bateau de
gendarmerie nationale et une piscine à
34000 € qui a été construite pour se
baigner à l'abri des
journalistes ah alors ça réagit dans le
public un peuin est-ce que ça vous
choque le public levez la main qui à qui
est-ce que ça choque
ouais c'est il y a quand même une
majoritéin ouais il y a quand même une
majorité on peut pas avoir des robots
enfin faut quand même aussi s'imaginer
que c'est des hommes des femmes et qui
ont besoin aussi de temps en temps
reposer leur tête c'est quand même on
peut reposer sa tête à moins de 45000 €
fautême non mais il faut quand même
imaginer ce que c'est non pour pour pas
faire de de la caricature c'est quand
même des présidents des ministres il
travaillent nonstop ils ont un boulot de
folie c'est vrai c'est quand ils
prennent du00 € la beignade quand ils
prennent du temps ils sont obligés
d'avoir de la
sécurité obligés d'avoir des des homes
des hommes et des femmes de sécurité
c'est quand même la moralité c'est qu'
faut voter pour un président vieux qui
se baignera moins oui ça plus de temps
pour se reposer parce qu'il dort pas
beaucoup je crois non non mais moi je je
je dis je je constate juste avouez que
c'est quand même un peu surprenant alors
400000 € pour le budget de sécurité
globale pour les vacances bon très bien
60000 € par bignal non mais quand quand
on remet ça vous parliez du budget de
l'État et des budgets des différents
ministères il faut quand même se
remettre voilà il faut prendre un petit
focale de recul et voir que c'est rien
du tout par rapport aux dépenses de
l'État globalement et c'est un président
il a besoin aussi de faire ce qu'il faut
pour pouvoir réfléchir et pour pouvoir
voilà calculer et avoir ça moi je dirais
juste un point c'est sur les
déplacements moi ce qui me choque c'est
que ok il met le paquet sur la
diplomatie mais c'est pas très réussi et
encore une fois ce président qui est
très pro entreprise pro j'yv et ben tout
ce qu'il fait il y a pas un retour sur
investissement énorme il s'est cassé la
figure en Afrique au Liban il y a pas
longtemps aussi il y a beaucoup de
fauxas beaucoup de problèmes de
diplomatie donc bah voilà peut-être
faire un peu plus chichement mais d'une
manière un petit peu plus de qualité ça
ça pourrait être valable c'est ce que
j'ais dire la notion de retour sur
investissement c'està dire qu'il
aille en balade ou ou réellement
diplomatiquement à divers endroits oui
mais de temps en temps on est supposé
qu' a une vraie efficacité à l'arrivée
pour l'instant c'est vrai que c'est pas
c'est pas pasant même si la diplomatie
ça prend des années des années c'est pas
pasant et le deuxième point le diable
est dans les détails moi l'histoire de
la piscine ça me choque parce que
jusqu'à présent tous les présidents s'en
sont passés et que là bon ben voilà
c'est c'est tout con mais c'est un
détail mais mais en même temps Isabelle
quand on voit la la baignade à 600 € ma
on 3 on a fait une affaireoi tant qu'à
faire puisqu'ils sont déjà là autant
qu'ils se baignent au milieu de non mais
c'est c'est c'est les symboles compte
c'est vrai que les symboles comptent et
d'autant plus quand on souffre
d'inflation d'un pouvoir d'achat
difficile et c'est vrai que je regardais
par exemple Charles de GA il faisait
très attention et dès qu'il mangeait
avec sa famille il comptait c'était lui
qui payait il éteignit la lumière pour
la petite histoire il faisait très
attention à ça et c'est vrai que piscine
et puis ils étaient moins modern et puis
ils étaient moins sous les médias tout
le temps donc ils avaient besoin de
moins de maquillage aussi probablement
mais il il y a ces aspects là
c'est-à-dire d'avoir l'impression d'être
exigeant sur son propre niveau et
quotidien de vie ça c'est important ça
je pense que c'est c'est pas ce qui
semble là le plus flagrant voilà mais
quand même bon les français
s'interrogent en voyant effectivement ce
ce budget qui qui a grimpé dans les
circonstances que nous connaissons 12 à
15 % de de hausse pour les déplacements
c'est ce que vous dites effectivement
les prix de l'énergie et les déplacement
du du chef de de l'État il n'empêche ce
sujet a fait beaucoup agir